die monde in unserem sonnensystem sind
äußerst faszinierend der mars wird durch
seine zum beispiel einen ring wieder
saturn bekommen
auf anderen monden ist biologische
aktivität und damit leben äußerst
wahrscheinlich und der saturnmond titan
hat frappierende ähnlichkeiten mit der
erde die top 7 spannendsten facts zu den
mond in unserem sonnensystem gibt es
jetzt hier bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen wir wünschen euch ja
nicht nur themen über whatsapp sondern
auch über die plattform paefgen vielen
dank dafür kommen viele spannende
vorschläge von euch rein
dort habt ihr euch ein video zu den mond
in unserem sonnensystem gewünscht hier
ist es fakt 7 biologische aktivität auf
den ice monden des saturns und jupiter
diese entdeckung ja die ist tatsächlich
ein indiz für die existenz
außerirdischen lebens hier bei uns im
sonnensystem denn an einigen orten im
äußeren sonnensystem ist biologische
aktivität äußerst wahrscheinlich cassini
die raumsonde hat entdeckt dass das
innere von enceladus einer der größten
saturnmondes nicht tiefgefroren ist
obwohl der eysmondt mit minus 190 grad
eigentlich tief gefroren sein müsste
stattdessen die überraschende entdeckung
unter der dicken eisschicht einen 37
kilometer tiefer ozean im mittel
tatsächlich zehnmal tiefer als die
ozeane auf der erde
der grund dafür sind wurde gezeigten
effekte des saturns diese sorgen dafür
dass ein fester kern in dem gewässer
durch knetet wird und somit im flüssigen
zustand verbleibt also eben nicht fest
ist zudem treten aus rissen in der nähe
des südpols tausende kilometer hohen
dampf von denen heraus die analyse der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hat ergeben dass diese tatsächlich alle
alle zutaten für leben enthalten
stickstoffverbindung wie methan tätern
booten und panzern und salze ein ort
also im äußeren sonnensystem an dem
leben durchaus möglich ist genauso
übrigens wie die ice monde des jupiters
die ebenso tief unter ihrem sociale
verstecken nur der letzte kleine
schlüssel fehlt der end
wichtige beweis proben von
außerirdischen mikroben doch
wahrscheinlich ist das nur noch eine
frage der zeit aber wahrscheinlich dann
doch von erheblicher zeit fast 6 der
maas hat zwei kartoffel monde und das
hat konsequenzen die beiden kleinen
knuddeligen trabanten des mars deimos
und phobos werden oft auch als
kartoffeln bezeichnet wenn sie haben
viele beulen und dellen aufgrund ihrer
geringen gravitation haben sie eben
keine ebenmäßige runde form ausgebildet
im vergleich zu unserem erdboden sind
sie außerdem super kleinen verbots ist
nur 30 kilometer groß und dem mars sehr
nahe von seiner oberfläche ist ja nur
6000 kilometer entfernt deimos ist sogar
noch kleiner 20 kilometer also kleiner
20 kilometer zieht aber in etwa 20.000
kilometern entfernung seine bahn
wie beide entstanden sind ist noch nicht
ganz klar lange dachte man es handelt
sich um ein gefangener asteroiden
mittlerweile können sich forschungsteams
aber auch vorstellen dass sie durch die
kollision eines großen himmelskörpers
mit dem sehr jungen mars entstanden sind
so ähnlich wie sich eben auch unser
edmund gebildet hat feststehen aber dass
phobos auf katastrophen kurs ist jedes
jahr nähert er sich dem mars um etwa
zwei meter und wird so in lediglich 20
bis 40 millionen jahren also ist noch
ein bisschen hin wohl vom mars
vernichtet werden wahrscheinlich wird er
als krümel enden und als diese überreste
dann die werden dann einen ring um den
mars bilden
fakt fünf saturnmond titan ähnelt der
erde aus wolken regnen flüssige
kohlenwasserstoffe und bilden so
seenlandschaften zwar bei - 100 79 grad
aber eine gewisse ähnlichkeit zur erde
besteht und die bizarren ähnlichkeiten
gehen weiter in dieser frostigen welt
existieren auch dünen gebiete wie die
raumsonde cassini zeigen konnte mehr als
150 meter hoch und zum teil über
hunderte kilometer lang wahrscheinlich
wohl aus organischen feststoffen oder
wasser eis gebildet wie auch auf der
erde soll dafür wind verantwortlich sein
auch wenn es in der dichten atmosphäre
des mondes wohl eher ein laues lüftchen
ist ein forschungsteam aus tennessee
erklärte dies vor drei jahren aber damit
dass der wind wohl zweimal während eines
autoren jahres umkehrt die
atmosphärischen verhältnisse ändern sich
demnach wenn der sonnenschein den
an äquator überschreitet und sich die
winde für kurze zeit drehen dann
erreichen sie wohl hohe
geschwindigkeiten und sind in der lage
diese dünnen zu formen sagt vier helium
3 als neuer energie lieferant von
unserem ehrt mond wir hatten hier schon
einmal darüber berichtet forschungsteams
weltweit spekulieren auf brennstoff vom
mond für die erde
was auf den ersten blick nach science
fiction klingt könnte schon bald
realität werden ein möglicher kandidat
helium-3 das als treibstoff für
fusionsreaktoren fungieren könnte das
isotop soll von robotern auf dem mond
abgebaut und dann zur erde transportiert
werden chinas nächste mond mission soll
genau das verwirklichen helium-3 ist
besteht aus einem neutron und zwei
protonen und ist ein gigantischer
energieträger mit einer tonne des
isotops könnte eine 7 millionen
einwohner stadt wohl ein jahr lang mit
strom versorgt werden
dafür wird das 3 wertige helium benötigt
das auf der erde kaum vorkommen denn es
stammt aus dem sonnenwind der den mond
aufgrund seines fehlenden magnetfeldes
erreicht so kann sich das helium 3 dort
anlagern das isotop eignet sich
hervorragend als brennstoff für die
kernfusion bei der fusion mit dem
wasserstoff isotop deuterium
beispielsweise entstünde als endprodukt
helium 4
der große vorteil ist entsteht keine
radioaktive strahlung einen kleinen
nachteil gibt es aber auch zumindest
derzeit denn bislang sind noch keine
reaktoren entwickelt worden in denen das
helium 3 verbrannt werden könnte keiner
der reaktoren hat eine positive
energiebilanz denn das große problem ist
braucht sehr hohen druck und
temperaturen um zwei positiv geladene
atomkerne zu verschmelzen und das ist
mit heutiger technik noch wohlgemerkt
noch nicht möglich fakt 3
der saturn hat mehr als 70 monde und
venus und merkur keinen wer alle wissen
die erde hat einen mond weiter geht es
mit dem mars der zwei monate hat und
jupiter und saturn haben sogar jeweils
rund 60 bzw 70 merkur und venus dagegen
keinen einzigen der mond eines planeten
kann auf zwei verschiedene arten und
weise entstehen entweder der planet
bildet sich zuerst und fängt später
einen kleineren himmelskörper während
also jeden 1
hab natürlich umso besser je schwerer
der planet ist dass es auch die
erklärung dafür warum saturn und jupiter
die meisten monde im sonnensystem
besitzen die zweite möglichkeit besteht
darin dass planet und sein mund zusammen
entstehen monde bilden sich dann aus
staub resten die bei der entstehung
eines planeten übrig bleiben
fakt 2 die erde und ihre mond bilden
eine große ausnahme nämlich eigentlich
gilt die monde selbst sind viel kleiner
als ihre planeten doch die erde ist hier
eine ausnahme denn im mond ist viel
größer als er es eigentlich im vergleich
zur erde sein dürfte deswegen neben
forschungsteams an dass er weder von der
erde eingefangen wurde noch aus staub
fressen entstanden ist eine kosmische
katastrophe hat wohl dazu geführt dass
die erde einen mond hat kurz nach ihrer
entstehung ist sie wohl mit einem
himmelskörper zusammengestoßen
der wahrscheinlich oder sogar bestimmt
halb so groß war wie sie selbst eine
unvorstellbare explosion so stark dass
die junge erde wieder
zusammengeschmolzen ist zumindest zu
einem großteil der andere himmelskörper
natürlich auch ein teil der masse hat
sich dann in einer umlaufbahn zu einer
zweiten kugel geformt weiter abgekühlt
und ist wieder fest geworden genauso wie
die größere kugel unsere erde eben fakt
eins kleinster jupitermond auf
gefährlichem kollisionskurs
erst anfang juli 2018 wurde bekannt dass
ein us forschungsteam zwölf neue monde
des planeten jupiter entdeckt hatte und
er somit auf insgesamt 79 monde kommt
mehr als jeder andere planet in unserem
sonnensystem 11 der neu entdeckt monde
sind den bereits bekannten jupitermonde
nämlich doch einer dessen sonderling und
das gleich aus mehreren gründen er hat
nur einen durchmesser von einem
kilometer und ist somit der kleinste
aller bekannten jupiter trabanten auch
seine umlaufbahn ist merz
außergewöhnlicher kreis innerhalb von
eineinhalb jahren auf einer hohen und
gefährlichen urlaub waren in der nähe
der anderen monde
einer der beteiligten forscher scott
shepherd bezeichnet die situation als
äußerst instabil
eine kollision mit anderen objekten sei
demnach sehr wahrscheinlich also da wird
es demnächst knallen und das werdet ihr
natürlich als erste mit hierbei clixoom
erfahren und jetzt klicks und werbefrei
keine videos mehr mit eurer hilfe immer
wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung vor jeweils einem video im
monat ab bald ist es beim ersten video
soweit werdet also mitglied hier unter
dem video draufklicken und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live
streams wie kommenden dienstag und noch
ein paar weitere privilegien einen
riesen dank an all diejenigen die schon
dabei sind es werden immer mehr
wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle
videos informiert werden wollt dann
hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann
bekommt er den link zum video vor allen
anderen
von mir persönlich auf euer handy
einfach hier draufklicken und hier
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
darauf regenwasser eis auf dem mond
bestätigt bis dann bleibt dran